اهلا بكم الى النشره المفصله من العربيه
انا ميسون عزام واحييكم مشاهدينا نبدا
بالعناوين
المانيا تفتش سفينه يشتبه بتورطها في
تفجير نورت ستريم يدعو للتمهل حتى انتهاء
التحقيق
بيان ثلاثي اوروبي يعتبر تخصيب ايران
لليورانيوم تصعيد خطير ويحذر من انها
تقترب من السلاح النووي
قانون الهجره غير الشرعيه والامم المتحده
تقول انه يرقى الى انهاء حق اللجوء
وفي يومهم العالمي المراه من ايران الى
افغانستان يثرن رفضا لقمع السلطات
ويطالبنا بالحريه
اذن مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من التطورات
المتعلقه بتفجيرات خط انابيب نورت ستريم
واحد واثنين عاد الجدل من جديد الى
الواجهه بين موسكو والغرب بشان من يقف
وراء هذه العمليه فبعدت سته اشهر من
الحادثه يتبادل الطرفان الاتهامات ولكن
المسؤول لا يزال مجهول
اذا في صفحات هذا التصعيد المستمر بين
الغرب وموسكو حول تفجير خط نورت ستريم
ياتي اخر صفحات هذا التراشق الدبلوماسي مع
عودتي نظريه التورط الاوكراني في
التفجيرات قباله جزيره بورن هولم
الدنماركيه في سبتمبر الماضيه طبعا هذه
الاتهامات وهذه المره جاءت نقلا عن تقارير
استخباراتيه امريكيه واوروبيه وجهت اصابع
الاتهام طبعا الى جماعه مؤيده لاوكرانيا
مع ذلك اكد مسؤولون امريكيون انهم لا
يملكون دليلا على تورط زيلينسكي او كبار
مساعديه في الهجمات لاحقا نفى وزير الدفاع
الاوكراني
مسؤوليه بلاده عن الحادث في المقابل اعلنت
متحدثه المدعي العام الالماني ان النيابه
الالمانيه قامت بتفتيش سفينه يحتمل في
تورطها في التفجيرات في يناير الماضي
مشيره الى انه لا توجد بعد معلومات مؤكده
حول الد ارتفاع او ماهيه من قام بالتخطيط
للعمل التخريبي لكن صحيفه ديسايت
الالمانيه اشارت الى ان القارب الذي تم
العثور عليه تم استئجاره من قبل اوكرانيين
او بالاحرى اوكرانيين اثنين من شركه ومقر
هذه الشركه بولندا العمليه نفذها فريق
كوماندوز اوكراني مؤلف من سته اشخاص من
بينهم سيده نقلوا المتفجرات على القارب
ابحروا من ميناء روستوك بالمانيا طبعا كل
هذا بحسب الصحيفه لم يتاخر رد موسكو حيث
قال الكرملين ان التقارير الاخيره هدفها
تحويل الانتباه عن الفاعل بالطبع كيف بحسب
روايه موسكو وتساءل بسكوف كيف يمكن
للولايات المتحده افتراض اي شيء حول
الهجمات بدون تحقيق
من يقف وراء تفجير خطي انابيب نور ستريم
صحيفه ديتسايت الالمانيه كشفت ان محققين
دوليين عثروا على القارب الذي استخدم
لتفخيخ انابيب نورت ستريم وان منفذي
العمليه فريق كوماندوس اوكراني
الحكومه الالمانيه اكدت ان التحقيق
المشترك مع الدنمارك والسويد بشان تفجير
نورت ستريم مستمر ولم يصل لنتيجه بعد
صحيفه كشفت عن تقييم للاستخبارات
الامريكيه اشار الى ان مجموعه اوكرانيه
نفذت الهجوم على خطوط
العام الماضي
التقرير الذي يتحدث عن تورط اوكرانيا
بالتفجير نوت ستريم يبرر طلب موسكو اجراء
تحقيق مستقل بهذا الشان هذا ما قاله مندوب
روسيا الدائم لدى الامم المتحده فاسلي
نيبيزيا
من جانبها اعلنت الرئاسه الاوكرانيه ان
كياث غير متورطه على الاطلاق في الاعتداء
على خطي انابيب لوردسرين ولا معلومات
لديها عما حدث
في هذا الاطار اكد الامين العام لحلف شمال
الا انه لم يتم تحديد المسؤول عن تفجير خط
نورت ستريم للغاز تحت بحر البلطيق حتى هذه
اللحظه مؤكدا ضروره انتظار التحقيقات
النهائيه
ما نفعله الان كان هناك هجوم على خط عمل
تخريبي لكن لم نتمكن من تحديد المسؤول
توجد التحقيقات محليه مستمره ومن الصواب
ان ننتظر نتائجها قبل ان نقول من وراء
التفجير ولكن هذا يظهر اهميه حمايه البنيه
التحتيه في البحار فتوجد الاف الكيلومترات
من انابيب الغاز والنفط وشبكات الكهرباء
وايضا كابلات الانترنت وهي بنيه تحتيه
ضروريه للمجتمعتنا
المزيد معنا من موسكو عبد الجواد الرشد
مراسل العربيه اهلا بك عبد الجواد اسمح لي
ان ابدا بالموقف الروسي ما الذي اغضب
روسيا وخاصه استمعنا سيلتنبرغ وايضا
الالمان يقولون لا زال الوقت مبكر للوصول
الى نتيجه بمعنى اخر نتحدث عن نظريات الان
مرحبا ميسون وكل عام وانت بخير نعم يعني
في الحقيقه موسكو تنظر الى التقارير
والتسريبات التي تنشر على وسائل اعلام
الغربيه بانها محاوله غير موفقه لابعاد
الشبهات وابعاد الموقف الصحيح عن الفاعلين
وعن منفذي هذه العمليه وتطالب طبعا بفتح
تحقيق وتشكيل لجنه دوليه تضم جميع الدول
التي استثمرت في نورد ستريم بدعم من الامم
المتحده للوقوف على تفاصيل هذا الموضوع
طبعا موسكو ترى بان المتضرر ليست روسيا
وحدها باعتبار ان نورد ستريم كانت تلعب
دور محرري محوري في ملف امن الطاقه وان
كثيرا من الدول الاوروبيه تضررت جراء هذا
الفعل طبعا عوده هذا الموضوع ياتي بعد
التقارير الغربيه التي تتحدث عن هذه
الروايه التي طبعا تحدثت عنها موسكو بانها
غير صحيحه نوعا ما الكثير من القراءات
والتحليلات اليوم في البلاد ميسون تتحدث
عن هذا الموضوع بان نوردستريم اصبحت موسكو
واصبح هؤلاء المتحدثون يقولون على العلم
بان واشنطن
متورطتان بشكل كبير هو ان هذا العمل هو
عمل ارهابي كان لابد من يعني الوقود
وضع النقطه دون الوصول اليه لانه طبعا لعب
دور محرز في ضرب ملف امن الطاقه في القاره
وهذا ليس بالموضوع الجديد
عن الموقف الروسي فقط لنفهم كيف يفكر
الروس لانه قضيه البريطانيين بان يكونوا
جزء من هذه العمليه ليست بالموضوع الجديد
وحتى الامريكان خرجت حتى مقالات امريكيه
تتعلق بهذا الموضوع ولكن لماذا تحريك هذا
الملف الان في هذا التوقيت كيف يمكن
لروسيا ان تستفيد من اثارته الان
يعني موسكو تسعى للوصول للحقيقه في هذا
الموضوع طبعا هي ليس تحاول الدخول في
اللجنه الدوليه التي قد تشكل للبحث في هذا
الموضوع حاولت كثيرا الوصول للوثائق التي
اجرتها السويد والنرويج خلال عمليه
التحقيقات لكن لم تصل لشيء كل الطرق مغلقه
في وجهها كما تحدث وكما تحدثت الخارجيه
لذلك تبحث عن بصيص امل قد يرسلها لهذا
الموضوع بالرغم من انها تقوم بايصال رسائل
مبطنه حول نيه الفاعل ووجهته ومن هو يكون
لذلك طبعا ميسون هذه القضيه ليست جديده لن
تكون جديده اليوم وفي المستقبل طبعا
ستتحدث عنها
وستستخدمها على ما يبدو في ملفات ضغطات
اخرى شكرا جزيلا لك
ميدانيا ومع اشتداد المعارك الميدانيه في
باخ متطلبه وزير الدفاع الاوكراني
طلب الاتحاد الاوروبي بتزويد بلاده بذخائر
اضافيه وعتاد للدفاع الجوي في اقرب وقت
كما قال لشن هجوم مضاد مع ذلك لا يستبعد
امينو عامي حلف الناتو من سقوط باخموت
خلال
ايامود روسيا تلقي بالمزيد من القوات وما
تفتقده من المهاره العسكريه تعوضه بكميات
القوات عانوا من خسائر كبيره ولكن في
الوقت نفسه لا يمكن استبعاد ان بخمه ستسقط
في النهايه خلال الايام المقبله لذا من
المهم ان لا ينعكس ذلك الى نقطه تحول في
الحرب وهو ايضا يؤكد ضروره عدم الاستهانه
بروسيا
ورغم اعلان مؤسسه مجموعه فاجنر شبه
العسكريه الروسيه يابقيني بريكوجين سيطرت
قوته على الجزء الشرقي من مدينه باخموت
الا ان قوات فاجنر لا تزال تعاني من
الخطوط او على الخطوط الاماميه طبعا هذه
المعاناه لا تقتصر فقط على المعارك
العنيفه على الارض ولكن ايضا هي مرتبطه
بنقص الذخيره اشتكى مرارا من نقص الذخيره
التي تصل لقواته محملا قاده الجيش الروسي
المسؤوليه حال ادى ذلك لفقدان السيطره
ميدانيا مؤخرا
ظهر فيديو لهذا القائد قائد قوات فاغنر
يتحدث فيه مع احد المقاتلين على الخطوط
الاماميه ويشير فيه الى نقص الذخيره وايضا
نقص المساعدات التي تصل للقوات على الارض
وبينما تشتد المعارك على الارض في باخ موت
يستعد الجيش الاوكراني لشنه هجوم مضاد
جديد مستفيدا من طبعا الدعم الغربي وفق
تقرير لمجله ايكونوميست وما يقلق كيف هو
ما بعد السيطره الروسيه على باخمت والتي
ستكون مفتاحا لمزيد من السيطره على مدن
بالشرق بحسب الاوكران يقول الرئيس
الاوكراني
انه يدرك تماما انه بعد
ستتمكن القوات الروسيه من الذهب الى ابعد
من ذلك
ككراماتورسك ومن ثم سلوفيا نيسك ومن هنا
يبدو ان كيف ستتجه للامساك بزمام الامور
في محاوله لتخفيف الضغط عن قواتها فبحسب
انه بينما تتجه الامطار الان الى معركه
بلده باخموت سيتحول الاهتمام قريبا الى
هجوم مضاد متوقع قد يبدا في وقت مبكر من
شهر ابريل معهد الدراسات الحرب الامريكيه
يقول ان معركه باخموت روسيا وتمهد الطريق
لهجوم اوكرانيا مضاد مشيرا الى ان الهجوم
الروسي على بخمه اقترب من ذروته المعهد
يقول ان روسيا ستفقد زمام المبادره تماما
كما فعلت بعد معركه سيفرو دونيتسكو
بمنطقه
الى التحول في موقف الغرب خلال الاشهر
الاخيره من ناحيه زياده المساعدات
العسكريه المقدمه لاوكرانيا وهو ما يشجع
القوات الاوكرانيه على الهجوم
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
تظاهرات في اليونان بعد حادثه القطارين
تتحول الاشتباكات مع الشرطه
اهلا بكم مجددا نستكمل الخامسه من مخاوف
اوروبا بشان برنامج ايران النووي تعهدت
فرنسا والمانيا وبريطانيا في بيان ثلاثي
تعاهدت بمحاسبه ايران اذا لم تلتزم
بتعهداتها للوكاله الدوليه للطاقه الذريه
قالت الدول الثلاث انها لم تقتنع بتفسيرات
ايران عن اليورانيوم المخصب بنسبه 84% كما
انه لا يوجد تبرير مدني لتخصيب ايران
اليورانيوم بهذا المستوى اعتبرت الدول
الثلاث ان التخصيب الايراني بنسب متقدمه
تصعيد خطير جدا تحدث البيان عن اقتراب
ايران وبشكل خطير من السلاح النووي اشار
الى تقويض طهران لمزاعم سلميه لبرنامجها
النووي وعن التصعيد الايراني اكدت الدول
الثلاث ان ايران بهذا التصرف تشكل تهديد
للمنطقه والامن العالمي وهي اختارت
التصعيد بدلا من العوده للاتفاق
المزيد معنا من فينا راغده بهنام مراسله
العربيه اهلا بك راغده اذا ايران اختارت
التصعيد ماذا عن الرد
اهلا بك يعني الرد الايراني لم نسمعه ربما
بعد ولكن سمعنا من ميخائيل اوليان
وباسافير الروسي داخل هنا مجلس المحافظين
قال بانه دول الغربيه هي التي عرقلت
التواصل الاتفاق نووي حتى الان لانه
متحدثين يعني الغربيين السفيره الامريكيه
والاتحاد الاوروبي حتى الان قالوا بانه
ايران هي التي يعني لم تستغل فرصه التوقيع
على الاتفاق في اغسطس الماضيه عندما كان
الاتفاق جاهز امامها وبانه
وضعت مطالب اضافيه مستحيله على الوكاله
يعني ان تتجاوب معها ومن هذا المطلب قالت
السفيره الامريكيه اغلاق هذا التحقيق
الجاري بحقها في ثلاث مواقع سريه وقالت
بانه لكي يستحيل ان تقبل باغلاق ملف كهذا
او تحقيق هذا بحق اي دوله لذلك يعني بعد
هذا يعني الدول الغربيه تنقل من هذا
التاريخ اغسطس الماضي لتقول بانه منذ ذلك
الحين تصعيد خطير جدا حصل في برنامج
النووي وصل الان الى يعني العثور على اثار
يورانيوم مخصبه بنسبه 84% وهذه النسبه
تحديدا ميسون يعني بالفعل هي تشغل يعني
الاوروبيين يعني الامريكيين تحديدا ايضا
وهي كانت حاضره في يعني كانت حاضره بقوه
في التحذيرات التي سمعناها من الغربيين
هناك الاوروبيه الشديد اللهجه في الموقع
ربما هناك في بعض الاصوات التي تقول ان
ربما ايران تعمدت تسريب مثل هذه المعلومه
حتى تثير هذه الدول هل هذا الموضوع مطروح
على الطاوله او لا
يعني هناك الدول الغربيه تعرف بانه الان
ايران تحاول ان تعود بطريقه او باخرى الى
الاتفاق النووي لانه المشاكل العالقه
بينها وبين الدول الغربيه تتراكم هي لم
تعد مقتصره على برنامجها النووي هي الان
باتت ممتده الى علاقتها العسكريه بروسيا
وايضا الى يعني مساله حقوق الانسان وقمع
الاحتجاجات في ايران لذلك ربما يعني يكون
الكلام الان على يعني هذا التصعيد في
البرنامج النووي الايراني جزء من يعني
محاوله ايران اللي دفع الدول الغربيه
للقبول يعني التوقيع على الاتفاق النووي
بشروطها هي ولكن يعني الدول الغربيه
بالطبع لن تخضع ربما لهذا الابتزاز وهي
الان مصره على ان تحصل على الاجوبه التي
قالت ايران بانها ستزود بها الوكاله دوريه
للطاقه الذريه وفهمت ايضا من دبلوماسي
اوروبي كنت اتحدث اليه قبل قليل بعد يعني
ان صدر هذا البيان بانه خلال اسابيع قليله
لم يطلع جراثي الدول الغربيه هنا او مجلس
المحافظين بانه حصل تجاوب يعني تقني
وتجاوب مقبول من قبل ايران ستعود هذه
الدول لمناقشه الخطوات المقبله فهمت ايضا
بانه هذه العوده ستكون قبل اجتماع يونيو
المقبل لمجلس المحافظين هو الاجتماع
الدوري لذلك ممكن ان تكون هناك دعوه
الاجتماع طارئ لمجلس المحافظين قبل تاريخ
اليوم في حال عاد غروستي وقال بانه ايران
طماطل من جديد ولم تزودنا بايه اجورنا
راغده بهنام مراسله العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
الى سوريا حيث كشفت مصادر غربيه للعربيه
كشفت ان الهجوم الذي وقع صباح هذا اليوم
في دير الزور شرقي سوريا كان بواسطه
مسيرات امريكيه بتنسيق مع اسرائيل واضافت
المصادر ان الهجوم استهدف شحنه اسلحه
استراتيجيه ايرانيه مشابهه للشحنه التي
وصلت الى مطار حلب الدوله قبل ايام وتم
استهدافها ايضا ما دفع ايران لاستخدام
الطرق البريه عبر معبر البوكمال لتهريب
الشحنه
[موسيقى]
في تداعيات الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا
وسوريا وصلت حوالي عشرين عياده طبيه
متنقله الى شمال غرب سوريا مقدمه من مركز
الملك سلمان هذه العيادات تقدم خدمات طبيه
للمتضررين التفاصيل مع محمد الاشقر
تاثر القطاع الصحي بشكل مباشر نتيجه
الزلزال المدمر الذي ضرب تركيا وسوريا
وانعكس ذلك على المرضى الذين يعانون من
امراض مزمنه ويصنفون كحالات بارده
ويحتاجون لرعايه دوريه كهذه المسنه في
ناحيه جنديرس التي تعاني من امراض مزمنه
تضم العيادات المتنقله اطباء وممرضين
وصيادله يعملون على تقديم مختلف الخدمات
الطبيه والادويه المجانيه لمحتاجيها اضافه
لاحاله الحالات الحرجه الى المستشفيات
الخدمات الصحيه اللي عم نقدمها هي خدمات
رعايه صحيه اولي بتشمل الكشف الطبي الفحص
الطبي ايضا تقديم الادويه اللازمه للعلاج
بشكل مجاني بالاضافه الى ذلك عم نشتغل على
الجانب التغذوي على حالات سوء التغذين قدم
مركز الملك سلمان للاغاثه والتنميه وعشرين
عياده متنقله تقدم خدماتها في المناطق
التي اصابها الزلزال شمال غربي سوريا
ويتركز عمل هذه العيادات في المخيمات
ومراكز الايواء المستحدثه
عشرين
طبعا عم يتم او عم تستجيب لمراكز اللواء
المؤقته التي تم العمل عليها من قبل فرقنا
في داخل السوري عم يتم القيام بعمليه
الفحوصات الطبيه والصرف الادويه اضافي الى
نظام الاحالات اللي وفرته الفرق ومن
عيارات المتنقله بالتنسيق التعاون مع
الصفات الصحيه لم تعجزه من منطقه الليبي
عفرين تخفف العيادات المتنقله من معاناه
المرضى والمتضررين من الزلزال شمالي سوريا
المتنقله عده خدمات طبيه وتعتبر استجابه
للظروف الصعبه التي فرضها الزلزال المدمر
وحلا اسعافيا للسكان في ظل خروج معظم
المشافي والنقاط الطبيه عن الخدمه في
المناطق التي ضربها الزلزال محمد الاشقر
العربيه شمال سوريا
والى التصعيد في الاراضي الفلسطينيه افاد
مراسل العربيه عن قيام الدبابات
الاسرائيليه باطلاق قذائف على مواقع رصد
ميداني تابعه لحماس قرب حدود قطاع غزه
وذلك بعد تفجير عبوه قرب احد المعابر
الحدوديه اثناء عمل دوريه عسكريه
اسرائيليه في تجريف المنطقه فيما طلب
الجيش الاسرائيلي من المستوطنين عدم دخول
الاراضي المحاذيه للحدود مع قطاع غزه خشيه
من عمليات قنص
ياتي هذا في وقت عما فيه الاضراب مختلف
مدن الضفه الغربيه حدادا على ضحايا الهجوم
الاسرائيليه على مخيم جنين امس والذي اسفر
عن مقتل سته فلسطينيين واصابه اخرين
[موسيقى]
المزيد معنا من رام الله مراسل العربيه
عبد الحفيظ جعوان اهلا بك عبد الحفيظ اخر
التطورات عبد الحفيظ يعني عين على غزه
وعين اخرى على الضفه الغربيه بصوره عامه
وتحديدا جنين
امامي سلسله جنازات وعمليات تشييع للضحايا
يوم امس سوائل جنازات التي خرجت في مدينه
جنين لتشييع خمسه من الضحايا او جنازه عبد
الفتاح كروشه منفذ عمليه حواره والذي نقلت
جثمانه من جنين الى نابلس حيث تم تشييع
جثمانه هناك وسط حضور الاف المشيعين الذين
نادوا بعمليات رد فلسطينيه انتقاما لهذا
الهجوم الاسرائيلي على جنين عمليا شهدت
الاراضي الفلسطينيه سلسله عمليات اطلاق
نار منذ ليله امس اخرها كان لافتا قبل نحو
ساعتين كان هناك عمليه اطلاق نار باتجاه
مستوطنه براخا القريبه من نابلس وكان رئيس
مجلس المستوطنات موجود في ذلك في تلك
المنطقه وسائل الاعلام اسرائيليه تقول انه
للمره الثانيه يتعرض لعمليه اطلاق نار من
قبل المسلحين فلسطينيين وينجوا من تلك
العمليه اضافه الى ذلك ميسون ايضا الخليل
متوتره للغايه هناك هجمات يشنها
المستوطنون في منطقه تل ارميدا على
الفلسطينيين وعلى بيوتهم وهناك مواجهات
ايضا في منطقه باب الزاويه عبد الحفيظ
شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل العربيه كان معنا من
رام الله ومباشره الى ستوكهولم لمتابعه
اجتماع وزراء الدفاع في الاتحاد الاوروبي
بحضور الامين العام الى هناك
ان هناك رساله واضحه
الان حاله ما تجهز الترجمه
الاوكرانيه هي بحاجه لدعم مستمر
وخاصه في ظل ما تم مناقشته اليوم بحاجه
الى ذخيره للمدفعيه وهذه الرساله التي
سمعناها من
الرئيسكي في المقام الاول
ومن مجلس الاتحاد الاوروبي
وهذا الامر يعد ضروريا للغايه لابد لنا من
تزويدها اولا ومن اجل تحقيق هذا الامر
فانني اقترح
مقاربه تقوم على
ثلاثه
مسارات
ولا يمكن اعتبار هذه المسارات منفصله عن
بعضها البعض بل هي مكمله
اولا اننا بحاجه الى دعم اساسي من قبل
الاتحاد الاوروبي
ومن خلال رزمه يتم من خلالها العمل على
تسليم الذخيره بصوره مباشره تاتي من
المخزون الوطني الموجود سلفا حاليا
واي نوع
من هذه الذخيره سوف تكون من معايير النيتو
سواء كانت من عيار واحد خمسه خمسه مليمتر
او واحد خمسه اثنين وقت واقترح واقترحه
على الوزراء ان ان يتم تخصيص مليار يورو
من
التسهيلات الاوروبيه الماليه ثانيا اننا
بحاجه الى
عمليه تسهيل النقل ذخيره من عيار واحد
فايف فايف فايف مليمتر من الاحتياطات
الموجوده لدى الدول الاوروبيه والعمل على
تعزيز هذا القطع
سوف يتم العمل
بموجب بهذا الامر
على تعزيز
الذخيره لاوكرانيا
الوكاله الاوروبيه التي سوف تنظر
بالمشتريات
حددت العمليه المطلوبه من اجل هذا المشروع
ويمكنهم ترحي مسار سريع لتامين هذا الغرض
سوف نعمل سويا
وبذلك نخفض ليس فقط سعر التكلفه للقطعه
الواحده بل ايضا نخفض من زمن التسليم
ويمكن لمركز التسهيل الاوروبي ان يساعد في
هذا الامر وكنت قد اقترحت ان يتم تحديث ان
يتم تخصيص مليار يورو ايضا للمسار الثاني
المسار الثالث كما قلت لكم وهو تكميلي
لابد لنا ان نعمل على زياده قدره الدفاع
الاوروبيه من اجل مواجهه الطلب
المتزايد بالنسبه للجيوش ليس فقط لجيش
الاوكراني بل لجيوشنا التي
التي تقوم الان بتقديم جزء من مخزوناتها
الى اوكرانيا
لان هناك مخزونات يتم العمل على تعبئتها
على نطاق واسع اكثر مما يتحمله قطاع الدفع
ولهذا الامر اننا بحاجه الى تعزيز
قدرهنا التصنيعيه من مواد الذخيره وان
نقوم بتعزيز
كان هناك حضور للامين العام لحلف شمال
الاطلس
وايضا هناك ايضا وجود لنظيره الاوكراني
استمعنا الى كلمه طبعا جوزيف بوريل والذي
تحدث فيها عن ثلاث مسارات تتعلق بتسليم
الذخيره والاسلحه وايضا الدعم المالي
لاوكرانيا
نكمل الى اليونان نتحول تحولت التظاهرات
تعبيرا عن الغضب جراء حادث تصادم القطارين
التي اودت بحياته 57 شخصا تحولت الى
اشتباكات مع الشرطه قبل ذلك قالت الشرطه
ان نحو 50 الف متظاهر احتجوا في العاصمه
اثنا بعدما تصاعد الغضب في اسوا ماساه
للسكك الحديديه تواجه البلاد
وقد توقفت خدمات النقل في اليونان نتيجه
الاضراب الذي دعت اليها اليه نقابات
العمال لاحتجاجا على الحادثه حادثه اصطدام
القطرين وادت الاضرابات الى تعطل وسائل
النقل العام فيما تعهد رئيس الوزراء والذي
يواجه انتخابات قبل حلول الصيف المقبل
تعهد بالتعاون الكامل مع تحقيق قضائي لكشف
ملابسات الحادث
في الخامسه ولكن بعد قليل
الاثيوبيه يمكن ان يحمل معه خطرا جما على
مصر وزير خارجيه مصر يحذر اثيوبيا من
المضي قدما في ملء سد النهضه بشكل احادي
اهلا بكم مجددا الى الخامسه ونكمل من جوله
وزير الدفاع الامريكي للشرق الاوسط الرئيس
المصري عبد الفتاح السيسي اكد خلال لقائه
مع اوستن حرصا مصر على تدعيم الشراكه
الاستراتيجيه مع واشنطن السيسي اعرب عن
اهميه تكثيف التعاون والتنسيق القائم مع
الولايات المتحده في مختلف المجالات خاصه
العسكريه والامنيه من جانبه اكد اوستن حصه
الولايات المتحده على مواصله دفع وتطوير
التعاون والشراكه الاستراتيجيه مع مصر
وفيما يتعلق بالوضع في الاراضي الفلسطينيه
قال السيسي ان وقف الاجراءات الاحاديه
والتصعيد وحل الدولتين هو الطريق نحو
تحقيق السلام
وفي سياق اخر حضره وزير الخارجيه المصري
سامح شكري حذر من خطوره الممارسات
الاثيوبيه الاحاديه مع طبعا استمرارها في
ملء وتشغيل سد النهضه بدون اتفاق قانوني
ملزم الوزير المصري قال في كلمته امام
اجتماع وزراء الخارجيه العرب قال ان هذه
الممارسات تشكل خطرا كبيرا على الامن
المائي لمصر دعونا متابع
يعد سد النهضه الاثيوبي ابرز تجلياتها
الراهنه وذلك على ضوء استمرار اثيوبيا في
عمليه بناء وملئ هذا السد دون التوصل الى
اتفاق قانوني ملزم مع دولته المصب ينظم
ذلك بالاضافه الى التشغيل وهو ما يعد
انتهاكا لقواعد القانون الدولي واجبه
التطبيق وعدم التزام بالبيان الرئاسي
الصادر عن مجلس الامن في سبتمبر من 2021
تحديد حول ملف الهجره غير الشرعيه اعتبرت
الامم المتحده ان مشروع القانون الذي
طرحته حكومه سوناك ضد الهجره غير
القانونيه يعني انهاء لحق اللجوء وقالت
المفوضيه الساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون
اللاجئين في بيان على ان هذا القانون
سيرقى في حاله اقراره الى حد انهاء حق
اللجوء ما سيحرم الواصلين وبشكل غير
قانوني الى المملكه المتحده من الحق في
طلب الحمايه الممنوحه للاجئين مشدده انه
سيكون انتهاكا واضحا للاتفاقيه الخاصه
بوضع اللاجئين
وفي تفاصيل هذا القانون تحت شعار اوقفوا
القوارب اعلن رئيس الوزراء البريطاني
سوناك قطته الجديده لمنع المهاجرين الذين
يصلون الى البلاد عبر القناه البحريه التي
تفصل بين بريطانيا وفرنسا وما ان تم
الاعلان عن تفاصيل الخطه حتى اندلع جدل
قانوني وحقوق واسع في بريطانيا بسبب
اجراءاتها التي تغلق الباب نهائيا امام
المهاجرين سونات برره قراره واقراره الخطه
بعجز حكومته عن ايجاد حل القوارب المتدفقه
بحسب تعبيره حيث دافع عن خطته بانه لجا
اليها بعد ان حاول بكل الطرق ولم يبقى
امامه سوى حرمان كل من يصل عن طريق
القوارب الصغيره من حق اللجوء طبعا حكومه
سوناك وجدت نفسها امام معضله تتعلق
بالتفافه الالتفاف على قرار المحكمه
الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان والتي سبق ان
الغت قرار وزاره الداخليه البريطانيه بشان
ترحيل من طالبين اللجوء الى رواندا مشروع
القانون هذا والذي ينظر فيه البرلمان يقضي
بان من يصل المملكه وبطريقه غير قانونيه
لن يتمكن من البقاء او العوده اليها او
تقديم طلب لجوء فيها وسيتم ترحيله الى
بلده او المكان الذي قدم منه او وجهه
ثالثه يقولون امنه وتمثل قضيه المهاجرين
غير عبر المونش ازمه متجدده طبعا بين
فرنسا ولندن وفي ضوء ذلك سيتوجه سوناك
الجمعه الى باريس للقاء ماكرون الرئيس
الفرنسي في قمه سيكون عنوانها معالجه ازمه
الهجره غير الشرعيه وتعزيز التعاون بين
البلدين في هذا المجال
نحن لا نخالف القانون ولم يقل اي ممثل
حكومي اننا نخرق القانون في الواقع بينا
اعتقادنا باننا نمتثل لجميع التزاماتنا
الدوليه على سبيل المثال اتفاقيه اللاجئين
والاتفاقيه الاوروبيه لحقوق الانسان
والاتفاقيات الاخرى التي نخضع لها المهم
هنا هو اننا بحاجه الى اتخاذ اجراءات
رحيمه ولكنها ضروريه وعادله الان لان هناك
اشخاصا يموتون لمحاوله الوصول الى هنا فهم
يخالفون قوانيننا ويستغلون كرم الشعب
البريطاني ونحن الان بحاجه الى ضمان ردعهم
عن فعل ذلك نحن بحاجه لكسر نموذج عصابات
تهريب البشر نحن بحاجه الى منع الناس من
القيام بهذه الرحله في المقام الاول اذا
كانوا يريدون المجيء الى المملكه المتحده
فعليهم اختيار المجيء الى هنا عبر طرق
امنه وقانونيه
مزيد معنى من دوفر عروب عبد الحق مراسله
العربيه اهلا بك عروب بدايه دعينا نتحدث
عن تفاصيل هذه الخطه وان كانت ربما ستمرر
او لا ردود الفعل
مرحبا مرحبا ميسون يعني نحن ولكن ابدا
الان نحن في هذه النقطه التي يعني من هنا
تبعد هذه النقطه من كاليف في فرنسا رحله
يعني الرحله في القارب تستغرق حوالي
الساعه والاربعين دقيقه طبعا اليوم من
الايام الذي يعني الجو فيه رديء جدا ومن
غير يعني
من غير
المتوقع ان نرى اي من قوارب النجاه تصل في
هذا اليوم ولكن عاده ما تصل القوارب في
احدى النقاط على هذا الساحل من من فرنسا
ونحن نتشكل يومي عروض الامواج هنا عاتيه
الجو قاسم بالنسبه
لعروب
جدا
ولكن بشكل يومي يتم رصد هذه القوارب
هل هذا ما تقولينه يعني حجم هذا الاقبال
الدعم
يعني نحن نعلم بان 45 الف تقريبا من
اللاجئين غير الشرعيين وصلوا الى بريطانيا
خلال عام 2022 وهي ارقام كبيره جدا مقارنه
بالاعوام التي سبقتها طبعا قوارب النجاه
بعضها يصل وبعضها لا يصل نحن نعلم ان
العديد من اللاجئين غير الشرعيين ماتوا
خلال هذه الرحله في هذا الجو في هذا الجو
القاسي البعض منهم يتم اخذه الى مراكز
احتجاز البعض الاخر يتم اخذه الى مراكز
احتجاز في مناطق اخرى غير دوفر مثلا كنا
نحن الان منذ ساعه تقريبا في مركز يعنى
بمساعده اللاجئين تكلمنا مع هؤلاء
اللاجئين وقد اقول يعني اقول بان الخوف هو
الذي يعني
يطغى على مشاعر هؤلاء اللاجئين حتى ان احد
هؤلاء اللاجئين قال لي بانه يفضل الانتحار
مثلا على ان يتم ترحيله الى رواندا
وبالتالي الجو بالفعل هو ليس يعني سهل
بالنسبه لهؤلاء اللاجئين هذا بالنسبه
لقرار الترحيل لانها خطه التي
بالنسبه لقرار الترحيل لرواندا هاي من
المفترض انه حتى منظمه اكثر من قضيه انه
كليا لن يتم قبول اللجوء من عدمه من خلال
هذه الخطه الجديده ردود الفعل عروب هل
يمكن ان تمرر بالفعل وتطبق
هذه هي المعضله الاساسيه ميسون يعني
المعضله كيف سيتم تطبيق مثل هذه الخطه
سواء من الناحيه القانونيه او من الناحيه
الاخلاقيه من الناحيه القانونيه نحن نعلم
بان قرارات مثل ترحيل مثلا لاجئين الى
رواندا كانت قد توقفت بسبب بعض العقبات
القانونيه من قبل المحاكم الاوروبيه وحتى
من قبل الجدل الذي اثير بين المنظمات
المعنيه بحقوق الانسان وحتى من الناحيه
الاخلاقيه حتى من داخل حزب المحافظين هناك
العديد من الاصوات التي قالت بان السوناك
ربما يغامر ب مسيرته السياسيه من خلال هذا
القانون الذي يعني يتجاهل او لا يلتفت الى
الجانب الانساني الذي سيفجر ربما يعني
اعتراضات وانتقادات من منظمات حقوقيه وهي
قويه بالفعل في بريطانيا بشكل عام ويمكن
يعود تفجير العلاقات ما بين فرنسا وايضا
بريطانيا على كل من دوفر عروب عبد الحق
مراسله العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك وانتقل الى
الجهه الاخرى كاليه في شمال فرنسا فادي
الدهوك مرا سل العربيه ينقل لنا الاجواء
من خلفه وايضا اصداء هذه الخطه ان كان على
المهاجرين او المتواجدين من خلفك او على
المستوى السياسي حتى
اهلا ميسون نحن هنا كما قلت في كاليه
المدينه الحدوديه مع بريطانيا هنا خلفي
فقط لاشرح هذا المشهد هنا عدد من
المسؤولين في الجمعيات التي تقدم المساعده
للمهاجرين هنا اليوم يتجمعون في تجمع
احتجاج على سياسات المدينه حيث قامت او
بدات الشرطه ابتداء من مطلع هذا الشهر
بنصب اسلاك شائكه لتمنع المهاجرين من
العبور الى بريطانيا هم ينددون بهذه
التصرفات وايضا كانوا يقولون قبل قليل في
الكلمه التي القوها ان هذه التصرفات
عنصريه وهي تنتهك حقوق الانسان وهؤلاء
المهاجرين الذين يصلون الى هنا هناك اعداد
كبيره جدا من المهاجرين الذين هم حاليا
عالقون في الغابات في غابات مدينه
هؤلاء يعيشون هناك في مجتمع موازي حقيقه
هم لديهم كل ما يلزم يقومون بشراء البضائع
ويبتعونها هناك من بعضهم الب هناك عدد
كبير من المهربين الذين يقومون ببيع
المواد الغذائيه لهؤلاء اللاجئين لكي لا
يخرجوا من المناطق او من الغابات التي
يختبئون فيها هذه المساله هم يختبئون هناك
حتى تتسنى لهم الفرصه للعبور باتجاه
بريطانيا طبعا هم يذهبون اما عبر البحر او
عبر الشاحنات عبر البر لكن المساله باتت
اليوم صعبه جدا نتيجه التفاهمات بين
بريطانيا وفرنسا هناك تفاهمات تتعلق بان
فرنسا تقوم بنشر المزيد من قوات الشرطه
بمراقبه اكثر في الحدود وايضا بتسيير
طائرات استطلاع لكي ترصد هذه القوارب
وتمنعها من العبور الى بريطانيا
شاهد في بريطانيا هناك توجه لسن قانون
جديد لا يمنح اللاجئ بحال وصل الى هناك حق
اللجوء بل ربما يعيدوا هنا يمكن ان نتحدث
عن اعادته الى فرنسا سوناتا يلتقي ماكرون
ماذا نتوقع
يتحدثون عن هذه الاتفاقات وعن مساله حل
هذه الازمه لكن ايضا هناك ازمه اخرى قد
تواجه هذا الاتفاق او التفاهمات الفرنسيه
البريطانيه لان الاشخاص الذين ستعيدهم
بريطانيا الى فرنساهم اصلا مبعدين من
فرنسا هم لم يحصلوا على حق اللجوء او اما
انهم مرحلين من فرنسا او حتى انهم السلطات
لعلمة بوجودهم في فرنساهم مجال
اماكن عديده عن طريق الجانبين والخاسر
بالنهايه هو اللاجئ من كلام من شمال فرنسا
فادي الدهوك مراسل العربيه شكرا جزيلا لك
في يوم المراه العالمي خرجت النساء
الايرانيات في مظاهرات تندد بالنظام
الايراني وبممارسته القمعيه ضد النساء
خاصه في ظل حالات تسميم الطالبات في
المدارس والجامعات الايرانيه لتلقى
المعارضه الايرانيه تلقي التهمه على
النظام
انتفاضه بدات بصوت النساء وكانت النساء
اولى ضحاياها مقتلوا مهسا اميني كان شراره
التظاهرات في ايران واستمرت الحركه
الشعبيه في البلاد لتكون المراه متصدره
المشهد
تزامنا مع يوم المراه العالمي وتلبيه
لدعوه الناشطات النسويات اتجهت نساء ايران
الى الشوارع منددات بممارسات النظام
القمعيه بحق المراه على وجه التحديد
محاولات نسائي في ايران تحصيل حقوقهن بهدف
الحريه لم يستطعنا حتى الان تحقيق ذلك
السبب يعود الى ممارسه النظام الايراني
وقوانينه التي تقمع النساء
لم تغب حوادث تسميم الطالبات في ايران عن
اللافتات بعد الجدل الذي اثرته تلك
الحوادث واختلاف الروايات حولها فمن جهه
المعرضه الايرانيه تتهم النظام بتلك
الممارسات وسط مطالبات دوليه بالتحقيق
فيها بينما يصر النظام الايراني على روايه
المؤامره وانخراط متظاهرين في تصميم
الطالبات
عمليات التسمم المستمره منذ ثلاثه اشهر لم
تترك اي مجال للشك في انها منظمه ويتم
تنفيذ هذه الجريمه حسب الاوامر خامنئي
ينتقموا من فتيات ايران اللواتي لعبن دورا
حاسما في الانتفاضه الاخيره ويريد ترهيبهن
قمع وقتل وتعذيب وتسميم ممارسات ليست
غريبه عن النظام الايراني بحق شعبه عامه
والنساء خاصه اسماء كثيره كانت ضحيه
ونداءات دوليه تطالب النظام بوقف العنف
ومحاسبته على تلك الانتهاكات اذا عمر
العربيه
هذا في ايران في افغانستان الامر لم يختلف
كثيرا حيث خرجت سيدات للتظاهر في اليوم
العالمي تمديدا بقمع حكومه طالبان التي
تولت السلطه في اغسطس 21 حيث فرضت منذ ذلك
الحين تدابير صارمه على السيدات من بينها
حظر تعليم الفتيات كما منعوا النساء من
العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه والدوليه
[موسيقى]